good evening everybody welcome back to
minutemade park for game two of the
world series for 2021 then the roof is
open should be a great night and the
roof opened for the first time in 16
years for a post-season game the last
time the roof was open
was game three and four of the 2005
world series and tell you what it's a
different look for this place i know
they've not had the roof open for a game
here since may for tonight's ceremonial
first pitch
he was a member of the first astros team
to make the world series back in 0-5
heading out to the mound now to toss our
first pitch please welcome the one the
only jeff bagwell
and on the mount for the astros is jose
or katie this is his second career world
series start through five shutout
innings in washington in game four of
the 2019 world series and puts away
rosario to start the night this will be
a challenge facing freeman really good
stays on all the off speeds 3-2 to
freeman he's got him
[Music]
now the braves have back-to-back two out
base hits here at the top of the first
enemy now with solaire you don't want to
throw him many strikes
pitch on the way swing at a miss got a
fastball by him and the enemy is over
jose altuve digs in against max freed
who's making his fourth start of this
year's postseason one and one with a
3.78 era they won two and altuve lines
it down the left field line hooking fair
and that'll bounce into the corner
altuve on his way to second base as
rosario fishes it out and it's a leadoff
double for jose
and when now duvet goes the astros go so
one out of the runner at third braves
with the infield back for alex bregman
2-2
and bregman lines it in the center field
fairly deep racing back duvall he's
there back pedals to make the catch
altuve attacks he scores astros lead one
enough great at bat by alex bregman and
jose grakiti is the first houston
pitcher with three strikeouts in the
first inning of a world series game
accomplished that in the first inning a
strikeout
it's number four and now the
eight-hitter travis star no with nobody
on for atlanta in a one-nothing game
and sends that one deep to left field
and forget about it travis darno showing
off the muscles and goes deep to even up
the game at one his first home run of
this postseason
anybody up and down this lineup can take
you deep
travis tomahawk the high fast ball
inside it looked like him
hit it about eight rows deep so runners
at the corners and the astros with
another threat and jose siri to the
plate one for eight this postseason that
one hit a two-run single
jammed
it'll score a run
and a safe all around 2-1 houston here
in the second you can't teach speed it's
a broken bat slow roller towards second
base gets the run in and he gets on
board with that blazing speed and a
celebration by siri as he crossed the
bag runners at first and second now with
one down and the batter is maldonado the
1-1 to maldonado and that's a ground
ball through the left side of base hit
on his way to third guriel he's around
third and coming home the throw goes
toward third as siri gets there the ball
gets away uriel scores siri coming home
and he will score as well maldonado goes
to second and the astros lead 4-1
and rosario saw correctly what he
thought he could get the out at third
but there was nobody there swanson could
not rotate over to third base heads up
base running aggressive base running and
the astros are coming out hot with four
runs already inning number four which
begins with jorge solaire against jose
another punch out for katie
make it five tonight good two strike
pitch change up has solaire way out in
front you can see he's thinking fastball
all the way the ball just doesn't get
there jock was a strikeout victim in the
second 0-2 got him again
back-to-back strikeouts for jose or
keady he's retired six in a row six
strikeouts for urquity see the tumbling
action appears to have that four-seam
rotation it just dives down and away
from the lefties here's adam duvall he
comes up with two outs nobody on
into right
kyle tucker
it's jose or keaty's night the lead off
man is on here in the fifth will bring
dancing to the plane oh two swinging a
miss good slider down and away good
morning good afternoon and good night
dansby swanson seventh strikeout for
kitty and there is one away two out over
the third goes darnold and this inning
is up to freddie freeman 1-1 pitch that
is barrel through the left side and a
base in that'll drive in darneau braves
pick up the tally here at the top of the
fifth inning inning will continue
and now a 5-2 ball game here at the top
of the fifth now all these at the plate
an infield hit and a ground out tonight
first pitch grounded right at guriel
fields it down on one knee stands up
steps on first ending over and we're
through four and a half in game two of
the world series brandley with the two
out rbi hit his last time up
yup uh strikeout for round number two
and that's five strikeouts now for free
bregman now with a sac fly and a ground
out there's the one two to bregman
swung on and missed strike three
ten straight sat down by max reed
and maybe somewhere along the way
someone reminded him who he is snitcher
out of the dugout he's going to take the
ball from freed with kyle tucker coming
up two on nobody out dealing with dylan
lee the left-hander who takes over
to the right side all bees
out at second and that's it alvarez to
third and tucker at first and now yuli
stands in and that's a bouncing ball
left side and fielding it is swanson to
throw to seconds dropped by all bees and
safe at second base with alvarez coming
home to make it six to two jesse chavez
is coming into the ball game second and
third two out or team maldonado o2
popped up behind short
swanson says he's got it
and good relief work by dylan lee and
jesse chavez altuve one for three
doubled and scored in the first trying
to get things going with drew smiley on
the mound now veteran lefty his first
appearance of this world series driven
to left field hooking down the line
she's gone
she's gone
altuve goes deep for the 22nd time
in his postseason history
second most all time
tied with bernie williams at 22.
astros lead at 7-2
because of the little big man ryan
the closure comes in with the heart of
the order coming up for the atlanta
braves austin reilly one for three
struck out as last time infield shaded
to pole
wow riley one for four on the night so
one out and i'll be still at first for
jorge soleil and solaire drills it deep
to left field toward the corner racing
over is brantley into the corner and he
makes the catch
gets it into correa they throw to first
but it's not going to be in time to
double up all bees
a lot of hang time and bradley played it
perfectly into the left field corner so
two outs runner at first for jack
peterson who's over three 0-2
fastball strike three call at the knees
and the enemy is over kendall braveman
another in-season addition for this pen
and a good one braves down to their
final out of game two pitch to swanson
swing and a foul tip held on to by
maldonado and that is the ball game the
houston astros even up the world series
at a game of peace winning game two over
the atlanta braves seven to two
michelob ultra organic seltzer as real
as it tastes